do you know what mommies is they're the
kids that lived with her we're doing bad
things and that's why she's there
because she was actually with those kids
so basically I lived in the home I
didn't sell these drugs that is Isis
just I'm the girlfriend any crimes that
he committed while we live together I
was charged with the minute she heard
that door knock he said they had a
warrant for her arrest I turned around
and saw her you know hugging the kids
that was tough because she knew already
I want to try and tell your story figure
out a way to make something good out of
all this I remember that she always used
to play with me and she used to comb my
hair has been tough for the last nine
years without her being here
there are thousands and thousands of
people just like her serving the same
ridiculously insane sentences she did
not go to the police so she was guilty
well we cannot wrap our heads around as
a family as her brother as her children
is the sentence that she received
[Music]
and I see your
[Music]
you